okay Sicilian let's see how white reacts
to a closed Sicilian open Sicilian none
of the above Smith more gambit into that
I almost always just say you know what
no thank you no thanks I'm sure white is
booked up that's one way to maybe look
at things maybe that's at least the way
I'm kind of looking at it my opponent is
running with d4 chops III the Smith more
gambit probably booked up and I'm not I
don't know any of the lines so let's
take him out of familiar turf there so
now what this seems like a good start
where else is he going to go Knight f6
Queen c7 I might try to do a fishing
pole set up might not be a bad idea even
in this setup here let's try retaining
some flexibility here this is may seem
like a bit premature to bring the Queen
out like this but sometimes you'll see
this in the Sicilian and one of one of
the reasons is to watch over e 5 and
also again retain flexibility with these
guys right here so right now with this
move basically saying of course I can't
not going to be going for any pin on the
night but my bishop might be wanting to
play here and while it can't be playing
to see Five now can it alright night
here
yeah night here is right looking at that
G foursquare another one is going to be
what another one is going to be a six
ok
they def one apparently heading for g3
I got it just having to ignore
spectators there I got it 86 Bishop d6
Knight g4 all candidate moves I like hmm
does it even needed to play a 6 yeah you
know what what's what's going on here
I'm getting caught up in the routine do
you see what I almost just did there
getting caught up in the routine that is
absolutely unnecessary there's no knight
on c3 that's going to be making use of
b5 and I really wouldn't be doing this a
six move in order to play b5 because I
think a for would come real quick and I
don't want this this position open up
too soon i think i am the underdeveloped
side so i'll want to take that into
account the possibility in other words
for white to maybe open up the position
so now what castles maybe a four by
white looking to maybe get in a five as
soon as my knight moves and is no longer
controlling a five you could be seeing
this a pond come intention with this guy
and I'm not so sure I really want to
allow the lightscribe bishops to be
exchanged so I'm going to go with a six
right now which is stopping Bishop a six
and the reason I why I think it's a good
idea to prevent the light square Bishop
from being exchanged is because i am
valuing my light square Bishop better
than theirs it's on a wonderful diagonal
I think that is for as long as I
maintain control of this pond advance
the long as I maintain control of this
I've square this Bishop really isn't
going to be any problem forming here so
I could play d6 I could play my bishop
here I can put my bishop here if I'm
playing d6 like I forget about that I'm
going to do this because I'm viewing
this position is one where my deep pond
has more flexibility than my bishop it's
a rare case but that's kind of how I'm
viewing it right here maybe I'll play d
6 or d5 if i did d 5 right away my king
is in some trouble so I'm doing Bishop
e7 so I could get d5 in maybe maybe on
my very next move or after I have first
castled well of course be much safer if
I'm castle before I play d5 and there's
both open files right here but I'm
certainly looking into it that will
allow this bishop to come to life that's
maybe a little bit of a drawback
actually it's it said that on the
Sicilian side excuse me on the black
side of the sassoon and getting in d5 is
often the equalizing move but maybe this
is an exception because it's not always
the case that this King night makes its
journey over here to the King side and
there already are two bishops bearing
down on my Kings side two nights in
close proximity to my king as well
instead of the typical one night and no
I guess f4 is ready to be played I think
this is a mistake I think because what I
do after I just kick him away he has to
run back yeah let's kick them away I
think looking back on this position
there's certainly an improvement with
this last move by white as far as i
could tell i don't know that this pond
push the weakness that it has created on
g6 you know that's the one
square i weakened slightly I don't know
that it's really exploitable so that
said you know is it was it worth the
time invested I'm not so sure d5 what
else do I have here how else do i get my
rooks working i think this is the right
idea i think it is ok to allow this
bishop to spring to life on this
diagonal push take stakes i'm on the
bishop and i'm also may be getting ready
to play here with a fork I'm these two i
want i'm looking to pick up the bishop
pair essentially with this move right
now so let's see about things work out
maybe there's some sacrifices on this
square i don't i don't think right now
it's really working they have less than
one minute to figure it all out and what
is this night move doing ok i guess
still trying to get this F pot advanced
in but I think now I'm able to play this
night here because what is it no longer
doing I see what it is doing and this
one I'm saying right here is very
important in chest to question ask
yourself two questions what is the piece
doing what is it no longer doing it's
clearing the way for the F ponder
advance what is it not doing it so now
watching over a five and i'm pretty sure
and banking use of this square right now
is good hitting the bishop and now this
pond is being hit for a third time
indirectly by this Bishop two times
directly once indirectly if push i take
and then i take here i'm winning upon if
Bishop in I break the pin if Bishop
takes Knight I recapture f4 is not
available and I think now I just do this
and I'm up on a clear pond here Bishop
in I break the pin right away I have
this as a pivot square and maybe even
there's some tricks with the f 3 square
but very little time to sort this all
out the position has opened up in this
night is a bit off sides now
less than 10 trying to remove a defender
of my king side I think night here is
best I'm really not too excited about
bringing this Queen into my territory so
and I'm okay with giving up on back just
so that the position has stayed open and
I think I still have advantage here
let's just threaten to mate g2 no time
to figure it all out um good game let me
let me back up here let me see something
ok
okay let's hit that back button and what
else what's what's the scoop here from
your perspective from your perspective
okay so you're playing the white side
what are you doing Smith more gambit
keep in mind you do not need to
recapture this right away if you really
want to just play see four and say to
yourself you know I'm going to I'm going
to run forward with maroc see bind and
guard d5 follow up with Knight c3 so
look into this idea it's one thing you
could be running with there's no need no
rush no rush with taking this pond he's
going nowhere c4 night here even on your
next move and then you can be
recapturing but keep that in mind see
493 um I don't know if this is well I
think there's got to be a maybe a little
bit better of a setup how about how
about this I don't know about the night
journey I think the night position is
fine here but if you're going to try to
get this F pawn advance in maybe look to
this night move I think that's where
nicely my main suggestion is going to
come later on but don't don't go with
this night coming around here i don't so
sure about that maybe you can keep it
around to maybe focus on this be 6
square or something night playing here
or maybe a pond push and then the d6
square I think get more development and
get castled instead of running with the
night f12 g3 you'll see that in the
Royal el pez I don't know how how good
it would be in this setup but could it
can certainly be wrong these are again
just very rough thoughts from I mean
just a five-minute game and right here
is definitely going to be the other one
so instead that night move you really do
want to maybe make sure you could get
this F pawn advance in maybe night to d4
is going to be better so you can get
this in of course your night is a little
bit a little tender right there after as
soon as you move that pond it's a little
bit weakening if you are going to try
and get this F pawn advance in g3 is a
weakness
it definitely be considered a hole at
that point um so see something here okay
well that's my main thing i think you
know don't go with the night maneuver
can consider just castle right away
night d 4 + f4 and at this point instead
of night g5 what could be something
better 94 94 with the f4 idea i think is
going to be better here so i think now
it's trouble I get that D Phi break-in
and now my my pieces are jumping into
good squares and I'm up upon and that's
it's a big deal being up upon right now
fully developed so the improvements are
much earlier if you are going to run
with the night move consider 94 you have
the right idea because eventually you
ended up playing your night to h2 with
the similar idea to try and get f4 but
it was was just wasn't happening right